bienvenue à la dombass arena le stade de
la ville de deux nièces qu allons voir à
l'intérieur
ce stade de plus de 52000 places a été
construit pour accueillir les matches du
chakhtior donetsk devenu dans les années
2000 l'une des meilleures équipe
d'ukraine mais aussi d'europe
le shakhtar de niet n'est pas seulement
l'un des leaders du football ukrainien
c'est aussi un club réputé au niveau
européen il a remporté la coupe
d'ukraine à plus de cinq reprises a été
sept fois champion d'ukraine et a gagné
à trois reprises la super content et son
plus grand succès à ce jour et la
victoire en coupe de l'uefa que l'équipe
a remporté en 2009 certains matches de
l'euro 2012 ont également été jouée ici
l'équipe de france ainsi joué deux
matchs sur cette pelouse deux matches
dont un contre l'angleterre et un autre
contre le pays hôte l'ukraine à partir
de 2009 le chakhtior a donc élu domicile
dans cette enceinte mais hélas pas pour
très longtemps
ce dernier match à la donbass arena a eu
lieu le 2 mai 2014 au mieux le shakhtar
donetsk recevait leach au viet c'est le
shakhtar qui a gagné 3 pendant les
heures les plus sombres du conflit le
président du club a organisé des
distributions d'aidé alimentaire dans
l'enceinte même du stade afin de venir
en aide aux plus démunis dont
l'impossibilité de jouer à cause des
combats
le club a déménagé à lviv dans l'ouest
de l'ukraine puis kharkov et enfin à
kiev résultat plus personne ne joue sur
cette pelouse qui malgré tout continuent
d'être entretenu en ce moment malgré les
actions militaires et la situation dans
notre région
la direction fait toutes les démarches
nécessaires pour préserver cet objet
unique avec le soutien du gouvernement
de la république du ministère de la
jeunesse et des sports
nous essayons également de conserver
tout le personnel qui travaillait au
stade dans la période d'avant guerre des
spécialistes hautement qualifiés
capables d'entretenir
infrastructures l'espoir des habitants
de john yates qui est plus
particulièrement des amoureux du ballon
rond est maintenant de voir leur équipe
revenir jouer dans leur stade